داخل دار حزب الامه القومي طماط المجلس
المركزي لقوه الحريه والتغيير تفاصيل
تفاهماته مع المكون العسكري عبر مؤتمر
صحفي تحدثت فيه قيادات التحالف عن بنود
مهمه شملها التفاهم مع المؤسسه العسكريه
المجلس كشف عن اقرار كامل من قبل
العسكريين بهياكل لسلطه المدنيه ومجلس
للامن والدفاع برئاسه مجلس الوزراء المدني
تفهمات ترى الحريه والتغيير انها اساس
لعمليه سياسيه قديمه عنوانها الاتفاق
الايطالي
اسيا الان اصبحت ممكنه بسبب انه في اتفاق
من قوه كبيره على وسيغه المحامين وايضا
هنالك اعلان سياسي سيرمور غريبه وايضا لان
المكونه العسكري قد غبل اا بموسيغه
المحامين هو اتفاق المبداي اذا على هياكل
الحكم والسلطه في انتظار اي يشمل الاتفاق
النهائي قضايا العداله والسلام دون تجاوز
قضيه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري
واصلاح جيش واحد مهني وقومي وفي الترتيبات
امنيه متفق عليها فان بلادنا لن تستطيع ان
تحقق الدموغرافيه او السلام او التنميه
رسميا لم تصدر المؤسسه العسكريه ما يوضح
رؤيتها من مجمل ما تم من تفهمات مع المجلس
المركزي بين ان هناك من يرى في المشهد
بدايه فعليه لحل ينهي الازمه السياسيه
بدات همم خطوات عمليه همم باختيار تواغيث
همم حول التوقيع اتفاق همم ايطالي في غضون
همم 10 ايام وتوقيع اتفاق التفاصيل
همم نحوي شهر او يزيد كشف نقاط التوافق
والاختلاف بين العسكريين والمجلس المركزي
سيحدث تفاعلا داخل تيارات سياسيه اخرى
تفاعل سيضع العمليه السياسيه امام
التجاذبات واختبارات يتمناها كثيرون الا
تعوق المسارى نحو حل توافقي
ومن المتوقع ان تشهد الايام المقبله حراكا
سياسيا تقوده الاليه الثلاثيه لتحويل
التفاهمات التي تمت بين العسكريين
والمدنيين الى خريطه طريق تاسس لمرحله
انتقاليه اخرى في عمر البلاد نزار البداوي
العربيه الخرطوم